[موسيقى]
يعتبر خط iPhone 11 الجديد من Apple
تطوريًا إلى حد كبير وليس ثوريًا ،
فالهواتف لا تطوي
ولا توجد إمكانات 5G ومن
الأمام تبدو إلى حد كبير مثل
طرازات العام الماضي ولكن في الخلف ،
هناك بعض التغييرات الرئيسية على الرغم من أنها ليست
كذلك '  لامتلاك ثلاث عدسات ، فإن أهم ما
يميز المجموعة الجديدة هو
iPhone 11 في الغالب بسبب سعره
وأداؤه يكاد يكون جيدًا
مثل الموديلات الراقية الآن ، إذا كنت
حقًا في التصوير الفوتوغرافي ، يمكنك دفع
بضع مئات من الدولارات أكثر مقابل  إن
ميزتها الرئيسية هي الكاميرا ، لذلك كان هناك بالإضافة إلى
ثلاث عدسات جديدة في الخلف واسعة
وعريضة للغاية وعدسة تليفوتوغرافيّة ، كان الكثير من
الناس يسخرون من
العدسات الثلاث الموجودة على خط الموالية ، وكان بعض الناس
يقولون إنها تشبه ميكي تقريبًا
الفأر الذي يصعب حقًا رؤيته الآن ،
هناك أيضًا مثل نتوء طفيف على
ظهره أيضًا ، كان الكثير من الناس
قلقين بشأنه حقًا ولكني كنت ألعب
به لفترة من الوقت
ولم يزعجني ذلك حقًا  كل الشيء الوحيد
هو أنني أسقطت هذا مؤخرًا على
أرضية الحمام ولدي الآن صدع في
الجزء العلوي الأيمن ، الأمر المثير للاهتمام
حول iPhone 11 هو أنني لم أسقط هذا
، وهناك بالفعل بعض الخدوش
على الشاشة
[موسيقى]
كل ما قيل أن الكاميرا رائعة جدًا ،
لقد تمكنت حقًا من
تحديد تفاصيل الأشخاص الذين يسيرون في
الهيكل ، فالعرض الفائق
مدهش حقًا ، كما أنني تمكنت من
تبديل ذلك وحصلت على لقطة جميلة
للمساحة بأكملها ، لذا  عندما
تلتقط صورة عادية أو
ستظهر لك في الواقع معاينة لقطة فائقة الاتساع ،
تكون الميزة مفيدة جدًا ولكن على
الأقل في البداية نسيت عادةً
أنه كان هناك واحدة من أكثر
الميزات المحببة للكاميرا هي صورة
الوضع والآن يحصل على بعض التحديثات ،
يمكنك الآن التقاط صور لحيواناتك الأليفة
وهناك مرشح أحادي اللون على غرار الاستوديو ،
لذلك عندما اختبرناه في الخارج ،
لاحظت بالتأكيد المزيد من التفاصيل في
الصور الشخصية ، لذا أصبحت كاميرا الصور الشخصية في
المقدمة بطيئة الآن  - ميزة الحركة ، إنها
لافتة إلى حد كبير ، ليس هناك الكثير من
الاستخدام العملي لها ، لكنها ممتعة
حقًا ، ربما تكون مجرد شيء
ترسله إليك إلى صديق ، واحدة من أفضل
الميزات الجديدة لجهاز iPhone هي الوضع المظلم
الذي يتيح لك التقاط الصور في
المواقف المظلمة للغاية  سواء كنت في
حفل موسيقي أو عشاء أو استوديو مقارنة
بجهاز iPhone الخاص بي من العام الماضي ، أعلم أن
هناك فرقًا كبيرًا في جودة الصورة ،
كما قامت Apple أيضًا بإجراء تحسينات على
ميزة HDR الذكية الخاصة بها والتي تلتقط
مجموعة من الصور المختلفة في وقت واحد
وتحطيمها  معًا لأخذ أفضل ما
في كل لقطة ، لاحظت ألوانًا أكثر حيوية
للأرض أمام السفينة
، وكذلك
ألوان الهيكل نفسه ما لم تكن
مصورًا محترفًا ، فقد يكون من
الصعب تبرير شراء كاميرا قائمة بذاتها ،
لذا يجب  تقوم بالترقية الآن إذا كنت بحاجة إلى
iPhone جديد وكنت متمسكًا
أو إذا كنت حقًا في الكاميرات ،
فتأكد من ذلك إذا كنت على الحياد ،
فقد يكون من المنطقي الصمود  بالنسبة
إلى هاتف العام المقبل ، والذي من المحتمل أن
يكون عبارة عن خمس سيارات من طراز Jeep iPhone ، فمن المحتمل أن
تكون أسرع بكثير وستكون قادرًا على القيام بذلك
بشكل أكبر ، ومن المحتمل أن
يكون أكبر تغيير على iPhone
رأيناه منذ سنوات  يحتوي pro line على كل شيء
ولكن بالنسبة لمعظم الأشخاص ، وبكلفة أقل بمقدار 300 دولار ،
ربما تريد فقط iPhone 11
[موسيقى]